you
[Music]
I am very happy to introduce Patrick
Johansen yep who's coming he has been
doing a lot of very interesting work at
the forefront of I'm very much looking
forward to thank you so much thank you
so much great to be here um yeah so
pretty the last couple years so I've
been thinking a lot about causal effects
and the biggest reason for that is that
I'm working in something called a
clinical machine learning group at MIT
and almost all of the problems that we
work with with some exceptions are
inspired in some way by healthcare and
so just I'll go through a few examples
of what what that my mean one of the
very few were first problems that David
worked on in his lab was predicting
diabetes onset and as you know that
diabetes is a very large problem here in
the United States in particular but in
other words as well
and and this is your standard sort of
prediction problem you want to figure
out what's the risk of a person
developing type 2 diabetes so what they
did in this work wasn't part of this but
essentially look at the person's health
record or insurance record and find you
know predictors or
symptoms I'm sorry features that are
predictive of the risk of developing
type 2 diabetes so the question here is
like essentially who is at risk who
should we think about perhaps
intervening on or or treating
differently a more recent problem that
I'm thinking about is opioid addiction
which is very relevant on the East Coast
I don't know anything about opioid
addiction on the west coast but but it's
it's it's a very big problem in the
states as well and essentially what we
want to figure out here is what about
the health care system or what are we
about the way that we are prescribing
opioids now is driving addiction
essentially and over 10,000 people every
year die from overdoses related to your
prescription opioids so these are not
drugs from the street they're
potentially
so that we could prevent and you know
people need pain medication but in a lot
of cases we could prescribe less so we
know simple things like larger
subscriptions mean high risk of
developing addiction that's very
reasonable but perhaps we can figure out
other other reasons for others to
drivers so this and lastly I'll mention
sepsis management which is something
that a lot of people in machine learning
community have looked at when it comes
to sort of health care tasks and in
sepsis it's one of the leading causes of
death in the intensive care unit and
it's a complication of an infection so
essentially you can have really horrible
complications such as organ failure etc
and one of the first things you should
do obviously when it comes to an
infection is to treat the infection but
a lot of the things that we do when we
treat patients with sepsis is also just
management things like the blood
pressure the heart rate they Occidente
can all be affected by this and this is
a sort of more continuous task of
managing patients we have to make sure
that all these things are in the right
range so for example if your oxygen
drops too low you might want to put the
patient on a mechanical ventilator and
if you do that you might want to sedate
the patient etc etcetera so this is more
of a sort of sequential process and we
want to manage these patients so that
their long-term quality of life is good
as opposed to just making them survive
the first 24-48 hours or whatever they
spend in the ICU because a lot of the
sort of interventions that we do have
long term effects so these three
problems illustrate essentially like
three different modes of applying
machine learning in healthcare and the
first one being a very standard
prediction problem that I'm sure most of
you I've worked with a lot and
essentially figuring out who is at risk
of diabetes all instead is something
that we can do using just supervised
learning or prediction like methods but
the second one figuring out what are the
drivers of opioid medication and how can
we prescribe opioids differently so that
we reduce the risk of developing
addiction that's more of the sort of
causal problems
we'll be focusing on today essentially
we might be able to or you might
consider choosing between a synthetic
and a natural or cured you shouldn't say
medication but and we're interested in
what are the what is the contrast
between the responses under these two
choices of medication and the last one
is more of a sequential decision making
problem or reinforcement learning
problem if we want to treat it like that
but we make a series of choices where
each choice depends on the previous
choices but also what happened as a
result of them and this this will we can
think of this as a slightly more
complicated version of this in a lot of
cases but we are also interested in
slightly different quantity or yeah we
want to figure out what is a good policy
a good reactive policy for if we see a
patient in a certain state what should
we do which is slightly different from
this where in which we might consider if
I choose between these two things for
everyone in the population what would
happen whereas in the policy setting we
might not consider the whole range of
actions for for everyone so the sort of
broad theme of this talk will be to
predict effects on decisions and we we
need somehow causal reasoning to do this
this is well argue and I'm sure you've
heard this argument before from from
others here and the main thing that I've
been thinking a lot about recently is
that we have a lot of high dimensional
data in healthcare and it's not only
because of this quencher problem but
also the fact that we have you know
diagnosis information we have other
kinds of medical history and we have a
bunch of symptoms we have genetic
information in some cases we have x-rays
a lot of things that contribute to a
high dimensional data regime and then
the second part of this talk will be
essentially linking this to demand a
petition which is something that I've
done successfully in the past demand a
petition if you know as part of transfer
learning or an instance of transfer
learning and it has a lot of
similarities with the causal effect
destination so the last part is kind of
an open question but but I recently I
was working on a product of
essentially trying to figure out what
will go wrong if we apply something like
reinforcement learning without thinking
too much in a healthcare problem and
specifically I will talking constantly
about what's called off policy or
observational settings where we can't
run an experiment successfully so in
those settings what should we sort of
try to figure out about our policies
before we apply them in practice so the
types of problems that we think most
about in our group is something like
this or at least I do there's a lot of
work on sequential things as well we've
got they're a bit later so we can
imagine a patient coming into the
hospital she's 54 years old and female
and she has high blood sugar so this
could be a pre-diabetic patient we have
to figure out how can we manage her
blood Sugar's so that it's lower a few
months down the line and we can consider
choosing between two different
medications to do so and the question
then is a few months down the down the
line which of these medications will
have a better effect on her blood sugar
and these will be what we call the
potential outcomes of this choice so I
will denote here by y 0 the the outcome
that we observed if we were to give
medication a and y1 may be the opposite
or the outcome under medication B so in
a lot of cases we could perform an
experiment to try and figure this out we
can gather a bunch of pre-diabetic
patients and then test these two
medications separately and figure out
what was the sort of average response or
even conditional response in these
groups but for a lot of cases we can't
do that and it could be because the
patient groups are hardly the patients
are hard to recruit they might be
expensive but they're also some types of
interventions that we you just can't
randomize like forcing patients to smoke
to see the effect of that session so the
typical data set we will be thinking
about is something like this we have
some descriptors about the patient like
their age and blood pressure etc and we
have essentially I call them recording
which treatment they received previously
we know what their blood sugar was a few
months down the line we want to figure
out what is what among these choices of
treatment was the better one the problem
of course is that we can only observe
the the outcome under one of these
treatments so what we would like is
essentially to fill in this these
missing cells in this table and
crucially these these these cells are
not missing at random yep yeah oh sorry
yes so the question was do we also need
the do we also know the the blood sugar
pre prior to treatment and yeah that
would be a there would be a good feature
to collect for sure yeah so essentially
the this slide is meant to argue that
you're meant to illustrate that these
these cells that we want to fill in we
can't treat them as the standard
prediction problem in this in the sense
that they they're not missing at random
the the observations that we have are
not representative of the observations
that we want necessarily so that that
would be the goal of this this talk to
figure them out so I'll introduce some
notation to talk about these things and
the first being acts a big feature a
feature vector essentially or a correct
representation this could be an image
this could be some insurance claim
information we had treatment assignments
T which I'll for the longer for the
majority of the talk a little assume
it's binary and choice of a or B and we
have potential outcomes under these two
different treatments this would be y 0
and y 1 and our goal is to figure out
the the outcome under an intervention
for a specific patient X or a patient
represented by future X or the
difference between two internships or
the outcomes under two images so I think
that's easier if I just show what I mean
in terms or using a figure so this here
could be the outcome under the first
intervention the control outcome if you
like a function of X for example H and I
put mortality on the XS
it's likely that you're more at risk of
death when you're older and the question
is can we use a treatment to sort of
reduce this risk of mortality and that
might be the case we can have a function
that represents the outcome under
treatment that looks something like this
these are just invented but but this is
not it this is not unreasonable to
assume so if you're at you know high
enough age just nothing we can do but
perhaps in the sort of middle region
here the treatment has an effect so what
you can see is essentially a couple of
things the the effect of choosing the
treatment treatment 1 over R cubed 0
seems to have an effect in some regions
but not in all so we have what's called
a hydrogen a heterogeneous treatment
effect but also it seems to be mostly
sort of beneficial the treatment like
this difference between these two lines
which is what we're interested in is
mostly negative so you reduce the
mortality if you choose no achievement
one now of course we don't observe these
lines right these curves are the goal
with the study where we want to find out
but we observe only a skewed sample of
these curves this is what I'm it's
illustrated with a table before and we
might have a situation something like
this where we have a treated group these
should be 0 & 1 & not 1 & 0 by the way I
treated a group that's a little skewed
to the older population here that you're
more likely to receive treatment if
you're older and a control group which
is younger and even worse than this we
don't observe you know we don't observe
the curves in the support of these
densities either we observe samples from
these from these densities right so
essentially we might see something like
this where we have a bunch of younger
patients been that didn't receive
treatment these are the blue dots here
following the solid curve and we have a
bunch of treated patients that are a
little bit older and if you look now at
the the average response to treatment or
the average outcome in these two
different groups we see essentially that
the average for the treated population
is higher in the average for the control
population slow
but what we concluded before was that
the treatment was always always
beneficial so it's kind of surprising or
not if you've seen an example like this
before but it's or you can see is
essentially that these average did not
tell the story that we're interested in
because here it appears that the the
effect tau or the difference between
these two outcomes is this adverse on
average as opposed to beneficial and of
course this is an instance of
compounding this is age here influences
not only the response to treatment but
also the treatment itself okay so we
have two problems essentially as far as
I'm concerned we have compounding which
is what I just Illustrated that if we
look at the just a sample averages that
we receive we get the wrong idea of the
effect but we also have an overlap
problem which I didn't talk too much
about before but what you can see that
this these two groups are essentially
disjoint and we have to work with that
somehow and be typical the typical way
to solve these problems and causal
inference at least papers I hope not in
practice it's just seem that these do
not exists these three prongs and there
this is yeah well we'll talk a lot about
this going forward but essentially the
first assumption that people tend to
make in these kind of situations is
something called ignore ability in which
you assume that if you know X if you
know what caused the the if you know if
you have enough variables to predict
essentially the treatment assignment
well the the two potential outcomes that
you are interested in should be
independent of that treatment so if we
control for X we can estimate the effect
ow the other one is coma support saying
essentially that at any point along the
axis that I showed before or any point
in the coverage space we have some
probability of receiving any of the
treatments so if you want to compare the
difference between two treatments or the
outcomes under two treatments we would
need of course to have samples from each
and this is what I'll talk most about I
think today there's there are more the
sumptuous that you need like iid as
is one of them and and this
consistencies another that's saying
essentially that if you prescribe
treatment T you will observe the the
outcome under that treatment and this is
not always true
if a patient elects not to take the
treatment you prescribed then you're not
going to see that outcome clearly but I
will take this for granted for now and
I'll talk about the other ones okay so
we still have observed compounding we
have we still have could have variables
X that we need to control for so roughly
speaking what we would like is to figure
out what is the observed outcome under
treatment for a patient X but we only
have this function for the people who
already receive that treatment we only
see the outcome under treatment for the
treated so how do we connect these two
well there are a couple of different
solutions to that essentially if you
have the two conditions that I showed
before there are suite of methods that
you can apply to to do cross this sort
of divide and and three of the most
classical ones are these regression
essentially fits a function to each
potential outcome or each observed
outcome under a treatment and rewriting
I'm sure you've seen before in other
contexts if you haven't done this
essentially doing important sampling to
figure out what is the how do we find a
representative sample of the whole
population from the bias sample that we
have matching just pairing up
essentially people with similar
covariates - - to figure out what would
be their counterfactual outcome if they
had the opposite so I will talk mostly
about regression estimators today and
under the two assumptions that we had
before we only have to do regression to
find to solve our problem with some
caveats in the sense that we might not
have that's the amount of samples that
we need but essentially under those
conditions you get that the potential
outcome under a certain treatment is
equal to the conditional outcome and the
this is you can do this in a log
in ways you can solve these kinds of
regression problems in a lot of
different ways the most simple one or
the most perhaps intuitive for someone
who comes from our scene learning
background is to treat these two curves
as two different prediction problems to
solve origin to different estimation
problems so you can you can try and fit
the blue curve support Li and the orange
curve separately and take their
construct their difference to to get
your prediction but but there are also
methods specifically designed to
estimate the difference at once and not
solve the two prediction problems but
our problem remains that if our two
treatment groups are very different for
example if we didn't have overlap
solving these estimation problems it's
not like it's not gonna be easy at least
in the sense that we're not going to be
able to the error that we have on the
data that we observed is not going to
representative of the error that we
expect on a different counterfactual
intervention if you like where we assign
the opposite treatment so there are a
few different problems that make this
hard and the most sort of the most
relevant to this talk is that we have a
often high dimensional data so there
there are essentially two two aspects of
this that I have basically the opposite
conclusions one is this is this idea
that if we measure more variables we're
less likely to have left out something
that we need to adjust for compounding
and this is true but I put an asterisk
here in the sense that we're not
guaranteed to have less bias necessarily
if we include more variables this is a
little technical but you can show
essentially that if you include
variables that you shouldn't have you
will introduce more bias than if you
left them out let them out and the most
famous example of that I think is M bias
which is I'm not going to get into the
what that is exactly but another one
would be where you consider you
condition on a variable that happened as
a result of treatment or after treatment
I suppose before so you can introduce
selection bias and that kind of thing
but this I'm sure you're much more aware
of all the time because whenever we have
high dimensionality we have to struggle
with sample slices
in this case we also have a different
kind of cursive high dimensionality in
the sense that it's less likely there
are two treatment groups overlap as we
call it when we have more variables so
if you think about the matching problem
that I flashed before if you want to
find someone who's very similar to you
but had the opposite treatment that gets
really big it's less and less likely the
more variables you have or said
differently you could say that everyone
becomes roughly equally comparable when
you have a lot of data or a lot of
dimensions I should say which is not
what we want so the question then is how
do we mitigate this curse of
dimensionality and specifically what
I've been thinking about is can we learn
a representation or can we find a
representation of our data fee such that
we still have the two assumptions that
we needed for estimating causal effects
we still need ignore ability we need to
address Aria just for compounding and we
also need a common support of course but
if we find a representation that's
smaller than our original space there's
a chance that we can sort of bump up the
margins on this a little bit we can find
a better support or better overlap than
what we had before so if you think of
this as being you know the a large
number of covariates for example that we
want to adjust for just removing some of
the variables would be the easiest way
to achieve this we have a better chance
of having overlap so either I've thought
about this problem for a while a few a
few years ago I started working on this
and and what we what we did essentially
at that point was to start in draw
comparisons between causal effect
estimation and domain adaptation
so the question was mr. certain example
that illustrates how we can be useful
for ignorant or helpful and it's almost
it's the opposite like whenever we
remove information that it's less likely
that this will hold except for the
biases that I mentioned before but yeah
so this is that is actually the problem
like we want to find free to achieve
this but this is the constraint that we
have so the question again for the sorry
for the recording is yeah sure we think
essentially should I try and get the
largest piece so that I have common
support or better better say a better
chance of getting common support but so
that I still believe that I have ignore
ability yeah I think that's a reasonable
way to think about it this will be a
trade off for sure like essentially you
can think of this as variance and this
is bias right and in some cases in some
cases you might you know have an easier
time achieving this then you might
that's it might be more concerned about
keeping information that are moving it I
don't have a great general answers that
I question but but I think that's a
that's a reasonable approach to take
maybe after we see some algorithm or
theorem that you might
have a better idea of that I hope that's
the case so we started thinking about
the main app tation because turns out it
is very similar to what I'm talking
about
and I used to just say what I learned
from domain a petition here but
essentially I've changed my mind a lot
on on the topic of the main addition to
working with this problem so we will
consider just one side of the of the
causal effect estimation problem from
before and essentially we would try and
predict this this blue curve or there's
outcome under control medication for the
treated population so for the red points
we want to infer what is their sort of
location on approval and doing this
one-sided problem or something that once
a problem turns out to be the same it's
doing what's called unsupervised domain
amputation and in that specific
formulation so like the main temptation
is essentially the idea that you want to
learn a model or fit a model on one type
of data and then apply it to something
else one one distribution of data and
apply it somewhere else and what you
have the data that you have essentially
in these specifically unsupervised
domain amputation formulation is labels
from what's called a source domain and
features from that's that domain and
then you have only features from the
from another domain called the target
domain so you have features and labels
from the source and only features from
the target so these map to
counterfactual prediction in the sense
that these are your factual control
outcomes the outcomes that you observe
and you have your treated group but not
treated labels essentially based on the
you know slide that I showed a minute
ago and your goal is to figure out the
labels for the unlabeled group the
assumptions are very similar in these
two problems the kind of factual
prediction of the main application in
the sense that we have this ignore
ability condition still that I thought I
showed before but it would be called
something like her area shift in the
main updation it's issues written
slightly differently but the idea is
essentially that the labeling function
that we want to learn and apply in a
different context doesn't change between
domains so P of Y given
if you like is fixed when we go from one
domain to the next and one of the most
often considered tasks and domain
updation at least when it comes to the
machine on the community is to its image
classification essentially this is a
benchmark that if people are very
comfortable with and these illustrate
two different benchmark problems that
are often used and here on the top row
we see well I don't know if you can see
it but it's digits from house numbers
that have been cropped this is
essentially the the center the center
digit is the label of the image so 7 3
and 0 I think and the bottom row here is
M Necedah you've seen a million times
but what's happening here is essentially
that we use these images for for
learning and we want to predict the
labels of these images in the bottom and
I domain a petition for a algorithm
where a suite of domain names how the
domain Temptation albums achieve an
accuracy on m nests of about 80% or so
having learned only from from these SVM
digits and you know the random guess
would be a lot worse than that 10% or so
so so something seems to be working here
but what you can also see is that these
two densities or these two classes of
digits do not or images do not overlap
at all
there's measure 0 for the house numbers
in this set so so how does that work
we're extrapolating essentially well why
would we registration it's traveling to
somewhere we don't have any data and in
this example you can see perhaps a bit
better why this might work in the sense
that these are these are synthetic
street signs and these are real ones and
I mean they're like it look similar
right I mean that's they have done a
decent job synthesizing it synthesizing
a street signs but still we don't have
overlap in the strict sense of the word
so okay if if we want to make the you
know if we want to connect the main
attention to cause the causal effect
estimation when can we
when can we expect a similar performance
for estimating causal effects when can
we expect to do that even though we
don't have overlap I'll get to that yeah
exactly so I'll take the dissident
machine-learning view of things now and
think about risk minimization so I will
assume I won't assume that I have the
right model yep I don't didn't repeat
that question by the way it was we were
he was asking if I think about the
hypothesis cause essentially when it
comes to culture my destination and yes
yeah so the question is for the overlap
condition is I think about those as
being estimated densities or so the
problem at the data generating process
and for now we can think about is
generating process but whenever we do
something that relies on knowing them
obviously we will have to estimate them
in practice typically so if you compare
to I will not assume that we know say a
policy for treatment
yes so okay so the question is a if the
if the fee is you know invented by the
the practitioner or whatever how can i
connect that to the assumptions that I
make about the data and we will we will
see why that can be a problem later I'll
come back then so the risk that we would
like to minimize now for the purposes of
this this sort of part of the talk is
essentially they the risk in predicting
the control outcome so that's f 0 would
be our hypothesis for for the control
outcome for the treated groups I have a
1 here so R 1 f 0 is the risk for the
control outcome for the treated and
essentially this is just where you
expect the expected loss under on the
assignment for the treatment group and
the loss can be something like the
squared of also the 0 1 loss and and if
you do have overlap a way to get a
consistent estimator of this quantity
would be to use importance weights where
you take your empirical risk and
essentially just reweighed each sample
by it's the ratio of its likelihood
under the treated and the and the
control groups but as we don't have
overlap we can't do this because p 0
might be 0 somewhere so we don't expect
to have good overlap in high dimensions
and even when if we did in some sort of
extreme sense or in some theoretical
sense this estimated where they have a
very high variance so we're not going to
do importance waiting here so what we
can do is to take some inspiration then
from domain a petitioned and we can try
and bound the risk instead of trying to
estimate it using importance waiting so
we're not necessarily going to have a
consistent estimator in the classical
sense but at least we can figure out
maybe something about how poorly we're
doing or get at least a direction to in
which to optimize so if we have ignore
ability with respect to the variables X
we can write abound in the following way
wherever say that the counterfactual
risk or the the risk that we defined on
the previous slide is bounded by the
factual risk so this is how poorly are
we fitting the curve the blue curve for
the blue points and this here measures
essentially how different can you how
different continue extrapolations be in
your hypothesis class h to the treated
group so it's defined here and it's this
is an integral probability metric or an
IPM there are other formulations of this
as well the one bound due to Ben Devine
looks at something called the H Delta H
distance or in the edge distance there
are a few different formulations of this
but they have a very similar shape
essentially you're looking at how how
large can the difference between the
difference be between the expectation of
some function evaluated over P and value
of the Q so this is now saying as long
as as long as the loss function the loss
at a point X lives in this space H this
this bound is correct
so actually yeah so I'm glossing over
some details here but the what is the
condition that's necessary is that the
the loss of F for any F isn't here
it's an H so there's another formulation
where you get an additional term due to
the triangle inequality essentially
where you have the realizability of of
the label injurer in age okay so that
this people wrote down a lot of these
types of bounds over the last ten years
and what came out of that was
essentially a suite of algorithms that
attempt to learn a space where this is
made small but we can still do good
prediction okay
so the goal was to minimize an objective
such as this essentially what I showed
you on the previous slide but now I've
inserted a representation of our data at
feet so this is what we had from before
right so think about it in terms of you
have some representation or you have
some original space x1 x2 where the blue
and the orange are somehow separate but
now we've moved to a new space fee where
there are more yeah identically
distributed but we also want to make
sure that we can we can fit the data I
would that be able to so this was this
was successful in in demand education
and it was used in the examples that I
showed you before this is this this
objective or algorithm has been used to
to get those kind of numbers on the
benchmarks but what we did was to
essentially apply this to few causal
effect estimation as well so we instead
of having a single outcome we know how
to outcomes right we have an outcome for
the control and now confer the treated
but we share a representation for these
two predictions so essentially what we
do is to we take our covariance we learn
a representation and then depending on
which treatment we did observe for every
sample we we compute the loss in fitting
that that outcome either from the
control of the trees sorry if you're in
in the control group you
a loss from the control hypothesis etc
and what I am not showing on this slide
here is essentially this type of penalty
that would be for the shared
representation as well so this is now
vetting the factual data but also
penalizing differences between densities
in the representation space so it worked
for the main application it turns out
they were it's okay for for causal
effect estimation as well this is a
benchmark that's called the HTTP data
set where your goal is to predict sort
of learning outcomes for children based
on facts about them and their mothers
and it has been synthesized so the the
carrots are from a real-world data set
but the outcome is completely synthetic
and we compared to a suite of different
methods but I don't know if you want to
go too far into this table these are
these are methods based on various
versions of the New Orleans I just
showed you before but some what sort of
disappointingly the the biggest the
biggest gain that we saw from our work
was essentially the choice of
architecture so doing regression well
seems to do pretty well on this task and
this has been pushed for it like this
this number here is 0.67 we're kind of
doing the image net thing of optimizing
to test at us at some point I think we I
don't think we should read too much into
these numbers but essentially what I
showed you in very early on if you if
you do if you have ignore bility and if
you have overlap doing regression well
is all you need to do so I think that's
what's going on here we see some sort of
gain from this is and this is using not
the density difference penalty not the
pH term that showed you before but these
three are so we see some games but it's
pretty minimal it's essentially adding
some regularization yep
oh it's tiny it's like 17 carats or
something or 25 maybe so that that could
be one reason but I think yeah so if you
if you take the Emnes examples from
before it's the same kind of sorry it's
the domain appellation albums are the
same sort of family of algorithms but
again eminence is also kind of tiny so
people have applied it to bigger image
classification task but the cost will
affect estimation benchmarks are
typically pretty small dimension yep no
I think I will answer that soon so the
question is if do I assume anything
about the homogeneity of the treatment
effect because I'm getting rid of
information like a critic treatment we
got to kind of make sure that that's not
predictive of the outcome because then
we lose signal but idea assumption so I
hope so this this seems kind of it
seemed nice like empirically but but the
way we kind of have the luxury of
hindsight for these tasks that we would
like when it comes to the domain of
patient problems but typically have the
target labels and we can just see how
well we did but people have also chosen
those tasks carefully it's very easy to
break them and the reason that it's easy
to break them is that this can obviously
go wrong I said that this was a bound
but it's not necessarily bound for all
fee what I we had this assumption that
the the loss function or the the loss of
your hypothesis has to live in this
family age but the smaller you make fee
the less likely that's it's it is that
is true and in similarly when I
mentioned the the triangle inequality
version of this where you have the
realizability of the label in your
hypothesis class that also becomes much
less likely right if you remove a lot of
information so ignore ability need not
hold for the representation right we
kind of alluded to this a long time ago
but not only that we may lose
information in a sort of asymmetric way
if it's if it's always true that you
know the
the information that we remove is as
useful for the factual as it is for the
counterfactual or for the treated as for
the control then this term will go up
sort of the same way as this right so
there's we have a shot that there that
this bound still holds even though this
is even though the assumption of the
aloft being that is satisfied but this
can obviously go wrong and I have a I
don't know if I'm will have time to go
through this in detail but there's you
can write a very tiny example for when
when it's impossible to solve the task
in the way that we've solved it well
it's impossible to solve with any
algorithm in fact so these are
essentially your two domains the the
gray and the white so these would be
your source and your target domain and
the circles and crosses illustrate the
labels and everything I want to show is
essentially that if you pick either x1
or x2 as your representation you will
have a minimum density difference
because the big gray and the whites are
sort of symmetric here right if you you
will have gray and white equally if
regardless of the variable you pick but
only in one case can you perfectly
separate these circles from the crosses
if I pick X 1 as my representation I
will not be able to do that so the the
thing is of course that there's no way
for me to tell which of this is true
because I don't observe the labels on
the target so if the gray here is the
target it doesn't matter which I pick up
X 1 or X 2 I can get perfect source
specification but not target cosmetician
so this yep
[Music]
yeah so that's a very good question so
we the bound that we wrote down and that
doesn't hold it doesn't hold because we
didn't force it to hold for every fee
right so it might not hold for a
composition of ever what's the fee and
that is that is completely right and
that's the first easy fix and that's
somehow somewhat surprisingly missing
from a lot of papers doing this the
Menem teaching community has been a lot
of empirical work for the last couple
years at least a lot of it but but yeah
that's a good point so yeah I think I
should be a little bit I think I might
get to that question is so another way
to talk about this failure case is
essentially considering predicting the
effect of a drug T and we assume that
this T has an adverse reaction or an
adverse effect for some patients that
could be allergic to some component in
this drug and the point is that this
this indicator for an allergic reaction
that we might know that a person is
allergic to something it will not be
predictive of the outcome that we see in
in our observational data set because
doctors might not treat patients that
that have this property right so even if
we observe this this in our data even
even if we have the the indicator we
will throw it out if we do some variable
selection or something like that so this
is an easy way this can go wrong so
another problem with existing domain of
tation methods and I'll soon come to
what we did I realize some very short on
time but I think so anyway but is that
the distances that you choose for
comparing densities matter a lot so this
is kind of a stupid example but what
we're trying to do here is to learn from
eminent
nice to em missed but a smaller version
of em missed so we removed some of the
labels over classist I should say and I
show you a few different lines here this
daamn is domain out of Sarah new year
Network which is exactly what I was used
to create the results on the benchmarks
before and/or you can see here is as ass
I removed digits more and more classes
from my from my target domain this blue
line gets worse
but what's perhaps more interesting is
that this green line here has only
trained on the source data so actually I
think this should be no surprise about
this point but essentially what happens
is that when you remove digits from the
target domain your density difference
will be kind of artificially large even
if you have all the labels or all the
classes and your source you have overlap
completely you have you have this
difference between the densities that
you will penalize in your representation
learning algorithm this red line here is
illustrating what will happen if you you
learn your representation based on this
domain Aceves Harrell objective but then
you train on some label target data so
what it says essentially we can recover
we can recover a good class price I
haven't thrown away the information in
some absolute sense I haven't done
variable selection here clearly but so
all hope is not lost in that sense but
of course we don't have the trailers and
and another way to look at the these
results is to say that these distance
metrics they penalize densities and
differences in the way that we might not
want to or expect so these are two
examples example tasks that we can
consider we have a source density which
is the blue one here at target density
and you can see these have overlap
everywhere and we have a source and
target here and a lot of the distance
metrics that are used
consider this an easier task in the
sense that the distance is between these
densities are smaller here but but again
look here we
have shared sport everywhere we don't
there so we expect this to be an easier
task in terms Ixtapa
so what we can do essentially is what we
have done in my work is to come up with
a new representation learning bound that
is not going to be we don't have a shot
of solving this always this problem
because for the reasons that I showed
before it's impossible but we have
imprudent a few things I think one of
them is that we essentially do important
sampling when we can if we have overlap
there's no reason for us to over
penalize the difference between
densities so in regions where we do have
shared support we revert to something
close to important sampling in the reuse
where we don't we we still measure the
difference of densities between learn
representation between sorry yeah the
resident in the representation space but
we might get we might loose on the
realizability that we talked about
before so what this term measures here
is essentially the difference between
the label as a function of X and the
difference and the label as a function
of the new representation so if you have
an invertible representation for example
this will be 0 that 8 over there and so
that means that this this holds for any
representation but you will have this
term that you can observe at the end the
ADA so it it kind of does a fix in the
way that you suggested we need a
boundless sensitive to the learn
representation but we are left with this
problem that was impossible to solve
which is to say that there are terms in
the boundary we can observe now
something for us to work out is how how
does this behave when something Arab
snitch is almost irritable if I if I for
example something that people have
considered in practice is to add a
penalty to your bound or to your
objective which says that you should be
able to almost reconstruct your data
from the learn representation and then
is that going to be close to zero well
that remains to be seen
so the takeaways from this part is
essentially the domain of tation can
inspire
causal effect estimation I think I think
I mean they're in some sense
mathematically equivalent but if you
think about the allergy example that I
gave before that's something that might
hurt you more in causal effect
estimation because you have this very
you have this very biased way of
introducing sort of non overlap right a
doctor probably knows about the the
things that might cause adverse effect
at least some of them we have the same
old problems that we did before in
causal inference we don't really gain
much in terms of that but at least we
can think about new algorithms or new
new ways of solving or estimating these
effects I think the idea of learning low
dimensional representation or at least
having low dimensional representations
is crucial if you want to do if you want
to ensure that you have overlap so if
you want to do weighting or matching or
regression you really want to work in a
space that's sort of minimal but also
has the assumptions that you need but in
order to actually do this in practice we
need to figure out what are the right
assumptions for that that applies to a
representation learning algorithm
because there's as I mentioned there's
no reason unless you make it so that the
ignore ability assumption or co-vary
shift assumption holes in your new
learned space but we also can't assume
that we will have overlap in the
original space because most problems are
high dimensional enough for that not to
work so I unfortunately don't have time
to talk about the last topic of today
but it's essentially ok ok ok the last
the last part it will be kind of brief
but I mentioned early on that we have
sequential problems as well where we're
interested in figuring out what is the
value of some policy and that produces
an action given a state so this is your
typical reinforcement learning setup and
people have thought about applying this
and people have applied this to health
care problems as well so one of them I
already mentioned which is that of
sepsis management so yep
yeah absolutely for some portion of the
day let's assume that I yep yep so is
there what what you didn't use there is
anything from what I hear is the
information about the part where you
actually have identification yep as a
way of sort of doing a check on how bad
you're doing for the part of the
distribution that you're not using so
like for example let's say that you have
the support that's like on the unit
interval yep and so that that part you
got then you can imagine sort of doing
your best shot mm-hmm using this
algorithm a prostate like 0.5 0.8 yep
something and then I'm using the
information yeah yeah I think that's a
very good point so if I okay short
version of a question if I were to
repeat it essentially why don't why
don't I use the the knowledge I have of
my fitting error in the regions where I
do actually have overlap is that okay
so I think that's a very good question
is something I thought a little bit
about essentially this part here is
completely insensitive to how well I'm
currently doing which seems stupid right
in the well it seems unnecessary it
seems wasteful yes yes I completely
agree
yeah so one way to think about that
question is essentially if we go back a
little bit I'm very happy you picked up
on that
this supremum here it's you can think of
that as the the worst case law so we're
taking a supreme over loss functions of
your data or on your data but we know
that most of these are not going to
happen right we're only going to see the
losses that are consistent we're the
loss that we already observed that's
right so you could write you could write
that down the problem is that you have
to figure out how do i compute this
thing for for for that kind of
restriction how do I make sure that I
take the supreme of only ever things
that are consistent with the error that
I already observed and I think if you're
doing something like there's a
formulation of this where you're using
essentially an adversarial loss another
serial network for example I think you
have a better shot of doing in there
than for what we've used here which I
didn't go into very much but they're
essentially kernel-based this is like
the maximum you discrepancy I think that
restriction is tougher then what then
for example an adversarial Network so I
think that yeah that's that's a very
interesting question
yep oh cool for we will talk about later
I marry Emily here
wait say that yeah I think that's fair
yeah
so if you already have a sort of kernel
based hypothesis that's to match this
discrepancy it might be a stream
corporate constraint I think that's true
thanks for likely yes so let's I think
that's also interesting for the purpose
of analyzing the domain a petition
example further in the sense that in
there ComNet space that we use for these
classifiers it is likely that the labels
in the two different days are not that
for our part or the images from the same
labels right we were relying on some
kind of closeness if that wasn't true we
probably couldn't first of all we
wouldn't get those results but we also
couldn't break it as easily as we did
like we're relying on some kind of
closeness like that and having then this
consistency constraint would be useful
okay so people have thought about
reinforcement learning in healthcare and
in fact there are a suite of papers that
apply off policy RL to exactly this
problem where your goal is essentially
to manage a few different things the
most it's the simplest version of the
problem that people have considered is a
dosing vasopressors which is a drug that
artificially increases the blood
pressure of a patient so what happens
that often is that a patient that has
sepsis or a lot of people in the ICU in
general have breathing failure and are
put on mechanical ventilation which
means that they might have to be sedated
to cope with the pain of intubation
which means that their blood pressure
might go down and then you have to
artificially sort of tweak that so what
is the right dosage of vasopressors and
when should you take them off because it
can have long-lasting or long-term
adverse effects it's an interesting
problem now
if you do this or if you solve this
problem how should we evaluate the
policies that we learn essentially if we
come up with something using off-ball
crl we will get some policy out and we
want to have to figure out should we
apply this in practice and we have all
the same problems that we had before we
have the overlap problem we have the
ignore ability problem but it's just
much much worse now because essentially
what you could consider is the overlap
between all of these different choices
right or if this is the the policy that
you might expect in practice at least we
want to know what happens close to this
plus right but the the I know there's a
lot of there's a lot of research on
specifically this question did the goal
that you're typically interested in this
this this value of the policy which is
just the expected long-term reward I
think a little bit but but you know
essentially that the the this sort of
overlap problem becomes worse and worse
the longer my horizon is and I've
Illustrated that here just by by showing
that if you were to do importance
sampling in a setting like this
essentially what you're looking for is
patience in the data that are treated
exactly in the way that your proposed
policy prescribes and the further your
horizon goes this this sort of group
just gets smaller and smaller so
something called the effective sample
size is exactly this the the number of
people that you were left with at the
end even if this was your original
sample so I recently I was involved in
fighting a sort of opinion paper on this
and there are a few problems of course
that you run into that seems to have
been glossed over in the literature in a
lot of cases so this this paper was
mostly a sort of warning sign or sort of
a warning rather for these kinds of
analyses
and we know that important sampling has
very high variance because of the
importance assembly problem it's also
the case that some some treatment
regimes or some policies we cannot
evaluate at all we also have the problem
that regression is often biased and
there's a lot of good work on
trying to figure out how should we
interpolate between these two different
methods the compounding problem is it's
made worse in the sense that we have now
compounding variables that are time
dependent and so be the you know the the
the choice of a medication later might
depend on a choice that we made earlier
a very common thing is that you don't
try the same thing twice if it didn't
work the first time and we have to deal
with these kinds of things but so this
is something that has happened recently
people have looked at or researchers
that have published in prestigious
places have considered various heuristic
methods of evaluating policies and and I
hope at this point in the in the talk
you will sort of follow in the in the in
my explanation of why this is not the
right thing to do and this is an example
essentially what you have here on the X
X or Y axis is the mortality you have a
patient in your data set and on the x
axis is how different was the policy
that we gave or so the action that we
prescribe to that patient from what was
in the data and what they see is that
well we have this kind of u-shape here
that says that if you're far away from
our policy then your mortality is higher
and you can see why this goes wrong
hopefully that there's the this is by no
means representative any kind of causal
effect this difference between these
averages here so I just say like these
have been bend in some ways you can take
averages of patients but it doesn't
really solve the problem this is no kind
of causal effect because what are the
two interventions that I'm comparing
here between these two groups and what
what are you is there anything that
makes me believe that these the patient
groups that up here in this dot is
comparable to this this group here no
these are completely different patients
right anyone who's treated like this is
probably somewhat of an easy case
whereas here you can have patients that
are very very extreme cases for example
one reason that you might have a lower
lower than expected treatment in your
data or lower
unexpected dosage might be that the
patient it's already too late there's
nothing we can do and that's bad we
can't tell that from this plot at all or
it might be that yeah well if you
prescribe I'm not gonna go on you you
get the picture so you can get the same
figure I mean I didn't put the actual
plot here but you can get the same
figure for a random policy you can get
the same figure for a constant policy in
some cases so this is purely an effect
of the the bias in your data and not at
all about the quality of the policy so
this was mostly to illustrate that this
is something we had to think a lot about
I don't have a perfect solution for you
by any means but I thought it could be
useful to see if you haven't already and
the takeaway here is essentially that of
policy RL is only harder than the causal
effect the problem that I talked about
before overlap it's aggravated and
ignore ability is harder to verify so we
have we have an opinion piece on line on
this if you want to read that I haven't
done any of this work alone as I'm sure
you've guessed at this point I've worked
with these beautiful David and
[Applause]
sure so you're not removing any
information oh yeah yeah that's fair
so another way to say that is that you
might have okay so the question is if I
if I officially blow up my ex by
considering interaction I might have a
better charlie ignore bility but at the
same shot at over life that is true so I
mean in some sense you're talking about
malama specification there if you
consider any range of hypothesis
hypotheses it doesn't matter right like
adding if I can learn the interactions
anyway it doesn't really change the
problem yes I'm saying yeah it does yeah
it does and I should say that a lot of a
lot of work from the non machining
community has exactly that problem but
doesn't acknowledge it so I think
there's a very valid point a reason that
you might want to do that instead of
what I suggest is that you might have
some domain knowledge just has some
interaction sorry very useful and then
you get both a better sense of a
notability because you well you have
some prior information right but you
don't list you loose you overlap so so
that happens a lot in practice but it's
typically when you have something like a
linear model
ah so is there a connection between the
sequential treatment case and the
blessing of multiple causes I'm I
haven't thought about that I think that
the blessing of multiple causes has the
same issue in the sense that if you have
more classes you have less overlap still
and there's there's some there's a nice
blog post by a guy called Alex under
Dunmore who has thought a lot about the
Oh black question where he says are you
essentially that the blessing of
multiple causes is incompatible with
overlap in the sense that if we keep
adding things that have some influence
on the treatment we're not going to have
overlap the more we yet but we have to
keep adding things to get the boss model
to because it because their analysis is
essentially taking the very number of
variables to the into the infinite limit
anything there in between I'm not I'm
not sure I haven't thought about that
problem at all but I think one a typical
typical sort of source of power for
these kinds of things is where you
observe the same kinds of interventions
in different environments as opposed to
from the same density all the time so
think of it to having multiple source
domains rather than multiple treatments
because you are looking for invariance
is essentially right so there's some
nice work on that that I think could be
useful for that question I don't know
how exactly that were they seem off the
course
yeah so I think this is an excellent
question essentially the question is
does the curse dimensionally matter for
the variables that are not compounders
and no no you're completely right in
fact for a lot of for a lot of clinical
tasks what we observe is that you know
something like deep learning or it
doesn't add that much of a linear model
because the features that we've used are
pretty well-known and well-understood
and they've you know they're they're
collected for a reason so something like
a linear model works pretty well and
what I mean and whatever the reason I
say the head is that not only do we do
prediction well but we also know more
about the the sort of causal structure
typically in those situations but when
you have something like an x-ray image
it might be very difficult to reason
about what are the pixels that matter
and so so characterizing what part of
the space I need to overlap in it's not
so easy there and and the same could go
for texts for example text data or I
don't know if there's an audio data a
causal inference community it could be
so I think yeah the problem that kind of
remains what what interests me a lot at
the moment is you don't necessarily need
the same you don't need to see we need
to have the same confounders for every
unit either or every subject it's what
you need essentially is a minimal
representation to predict your potential
outcomes perfectly and you need overlap
in that space but again as you've seen
there's no way for us to identify that
from data you need domain knowledge for
that I think I think that it would be
useful to have a sort of shift in the
way we talk about it though because this
nobility assumption is often just put
out there as you know a sort of blanket
statement but what we need is to somehow
incorporate the the domain knowledge
right reduce all these problems and but
but again how to do that how do you
define how to write down the assumptions
for an image classification problem so
maybe I start with observational did I
do some fitting but then maybe I can
show like look these parts of space I
like them then maybe there are
directions in which I am pretty good
support and then some directions in
which I am for support but if I just
sort of orthogonalize that set of
directions effectively and get some
measurements right so so in some sense
what I can the question that's maybe
missing is what if I were to think about
now an adaptive strategy time to that
guide the next round of data collection
how do I sort of use these bounds to
inform yeah I think it's a very good
question so like in some sense okay how
do you how do we use the bounds that I
developed you would guide
the collection the the okay there are
similar answers to this one way I'm
thinking about that is essentially how
do we characterize overlap in general
like we need some way to write down what
are the people that we would like to
observe if we could and that's in some
sense a problem on its own but in some
sense not like if you work only in the
garage space and forget about the label
you were typically carried you will have
a more complex character session than
you might need because you might say we
have overlap neat and never know where
but as you also say like if we have a
very biased estimate of our label we
might get the wrong groups anyway I
don't have a perfect answer to this I
think what's what's what you brought up
there with the linear model is
interesting because typically what will
happen right if you have a linear model
is that your the fits the fit in part of
your space will influence the the fit
somewhere else you would exactly right
so having what are the parts of the
space yep I would accept right again
because I mean if you can apply this
clinical healthcare setting your n is
gonna be pretty small demo in many
settings that I apply in which are
online I don't say that okay
I know roughly for if I could each for
each data point data points that things
work for you probably needed you need
like 20 or 30 or 50 to the point that
will give you another maximum coverage
so one way to think about that is that
cover during explaining the the region
of space where I do have overlap is in
some sense harder than the opposite
because you need the you need the high
capacity model to to say you know
essentially the right model of the
overlap to say to sort of conclude that
we're good enough but it's very easy to
say you it's it's sort of isometric if
you have a if you have a very simple
model in which there is no overlap then
you know there is no overlap but the
reverse is not true yes in the sense
that you're you're horrible model might
be too too horrible to adjust for the
compounding so you might have bias in
that sense when it comes to the overlap
is slightly different if you forget
about the label then I agree with you
that it's it's enough to have a crappy
model as long as you can give me some
information where to look but it will
not give you a certificate for that you
looked hard enough so it's kind of a
symmetrically right it will sit will
tell you you don't have overlap but it
won't tell you you have overlap if you
have two lines
oh okay if you can yeah yeah that's fair
okay fair so if you have some
information or some idea that your your
the truth is in that family or close to
it anyway then yes that's completely
right okay thank you so much